Let's think about the
market for plastic bags.
And I'm picking this
market in particular
because there might be
some cost associated
with plastic bags that aren't
captured when you're only
looking at it from
the point of view
of the suppliers
or the consumers.
So right over here, you
have a demand curve.
And that's really the demand
coming from the supermarkets.
So this is the demand curve.
You could also view it
as marginal benefit.
So that very first bag
that gets produced,
a supermarket gets a
lot of marginal benefit.
They'd really want
to get that bag,
because then they could
give it to the people who
shop at the supermarket, and
they can carry their bags home.
But then each incremental
bag after that,
the marginal benefit gets
lower and lower and lower.
And this green curve
over here-- we've
seen this multiple times--
that is our supply curve, which
we can also think of it as
our marginal cost curve.
To produce the very first
bag, the opportunity cost
for that very
first bag is about,
looks like about
a penny per bag.
And then it gets higher
and higher and higher
as you produce
more and more bags.
And we have an equilibrium price
and an equilibrium quantity.
Our equilibrium quantity
looks like it's about 3
and 1/2 million bags.
We have an equilibrium price
of about $0.02 per bag.
And if this were all of the
cost and all of the benefits,
then this area right over
here would show the total,
the aggregate total benefit
that the ecosystem here,
that the suppliers
and the consumers,
or the supermarkets or the
consumers in this case,
are getting from
this transaction.
Marginal benefit higher
than marginal cost;
marginal benefit higher
than marginal cost.
This whole area is
our total surplus,
and we've seen that
multiple times.
But now let's think
about that added cost
that plastic bags have that
are not factored in to the cost
and the prices, or the cost and
the benefits right over here.
Plastic bags have a
negative externality.
There's a cost associated.
So it's negative because
there's a cost associated
with plastic bags that is
not being borne by either
in this situation, that
is not being factored
into the marginal cost curve.
You can also have
positive externalities,
which are a benefit.
Maybe you're talking about
the market for trees,
and society benefits when
more plants or more trees
are being planted, or whatever.
And let's just say--
And that negative
externality, that's
coming from obvious things.
You know, these bags
are going to be litter.
They're going to be on
the side of the highway.
The city has to clean them up.
There's environmental
risks due to them.
Animals might eat them
and choke on them,
and turtles might drown,
and whatever else,
because they're choking on
plastic bags and whatever else.
And so they hire some experts.
And this is not an
easy thing to do,
but it's determined that
the negative externality
of these plastic bags
is $0.02 per bag.
Or another way to think
of it, the cost to society
and the environment above
and beyond the marginal cost
to the producers,
is $0.02 per bag.
Now, given that, if we
assume this statement right
over here-- and it's
not an easy thing
to come up with this
number-- but if we assume
that this number
is true, what then
is the optimal amount
of bags to purchase?
And what are we
actually doing if we--
What is the optimum
amount of bags to produce?
And what are we doing when
we do produce this much?
And to think about that,
let's create a new curve.
This is the supplier's
marginal cost.
Let's create another
curve that is
the supplier plus
society's marginal cost.
So that first bag supplier,
his opportunity cost
is about a penny,
but for society it's
costing another $0.02.
So supplier plus society
is costing almost $0.03.
And so we can plot
out another curve
which we can view as the
supplier plus society
marginal cost.
So now we can think of things
in terms of total benefit,
or total net benefit, I
guess, that's happening.
That very first
bag, the supermarket
that buys it is still getting
that over $0.05 of benefit.
But now if we think about
the net benefit to society,
it's not this whole height
all the way down to a penny.
It's only this part
right over here.
It's only the difference
between five and three
is the marginal net benefit, if
you take the marginal benefit
and you subtract out the total
marginal costs, including
the externalities.
And so the next bag, the total
cost gets a little higher,
the marginal benefit
gets a little bit lower.
And you keep, it makes
sense for society--
It will keep getting
benefit from this,
if we think of the
entire ecosystem,
will keep getting benefit until
we hit this other equilibrium
point over here.
And once we get past
that equilibrium point,
now when we think
holistically, when
we think of the environment and
the government and all of that,
now all of a sudden the marginal
cost of each incremental unit
is higher than the
marginal benefit.
So if we were to
produce beyond that,
now we're incurring costs.
Now we're essentially
eating out all
of the benefit that
we would have gotten.
And if we were to produce all
the way to our old equilibrium
point over here, we more, in the
way-- I was just eyeballing it,
the purple area is more
than the yellow area--
we're now getting a negative
total benefit to society.
Or you could say a
negative total surplus.
And we haven't visualized
it this way in the past.
It's unusual for us
to see a dead weight
loss on this side of
the equilibrium point,
but you can also
view it that way.
So this right over here
is negative surplus.
And so what you really
want holistically
if you are the benevolent
emperor of the society,
and you really want to
factor in all of the costs
and benefits of the plastic
bags, the ideal thing
if you want to optimize
the benefit in society,
you would want the
equilibrium price
to be around here-- that
looks like about 350--
and the equilibrium
quantity to be--
this looks about 1.8 million.
And you would not want all
of this excess quantity that
is taking away, that is
less efficient for society.